ELECTED BUT WE CAN'T TAKE THAT
RISK.
IT'S LIKE AN INSURANCE POLICY.
IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE A
POLITICAL OPINION.
IT'S ANOTHER THING FOR MEMBERS
OF AMERICA'S TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO DISCUSS WAYS TO
PREVENT DONALD TRUMP FROM BEING
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
STRZOK WAS REMOVED FROM THE
MUELLER PROBE AFTER OFFICIAL
>> WHAT KIND OF TEXT MESSAGE DO
YOU HAVE TO SEE?
MAKE AN INDEPENDENT
DETERMINATION.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY OPINION ON
THE LACK OF THE FRUIT FROM THE
POISONOUS TREE OF PETER STRZOK?
>> I CAN TELL YOU THAT IF THE
EVIDENCE IS TAINTED, THAT WOULD
RAISE A CONCERN.
>> HOW WITH A STRAIGHT FACE YOU
CAN SAY THIS GROUP OF DEMOCRAT
PARTISANS ARE UNBIASSED AND WILL
GIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP A FAIR
SHAKE?
>> WE BE RECOGNIZE WE HAVE
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE THOSE OPINIONS DO NOT
INFLUENCE L ACTIONS.
>> THESE ARE NOT JUST POLITICAL
OPINIONS.
THIS IS DISGUSTING,
UNACCOUNTABLE
UNACCOUNTABL
UNACCOUNTABLE BIAS.
WERE YOU AWARE OF HOW BIASSED
MR. STRZOK WAS?
>> NO, I WAS NOT.
>> Laura: JANING US NOW A
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN A MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND JAMES FREEMEN FROM THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" AND A FOX NEWS
YOU SAW ROSENSTEIN IN HIS TM
TODAY.
HE LOOKED FRIGHTENED AND HE WAS
VERY DEFENSIVE.TESTIMONY TODAY.
VERY DEFENSIVE.
WERE YOU CONVINCED?
>> YOU GO BACK TO WHEN HE
APPOINTED MUELLER, HE DIDN'T
EVEN IDENTIFY A CRIME.
COMEY IS DOING A
COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
TRY TO FIND SOMETHING.
HE MADE A MISTAKE FROM THE
BEGINNING.
HE CRIMINALIZED POLITICS.
NEW WITH THE TEXT MESSAGES, THE
LEAD AGENT ON HILLARY AND ON THE
TAKING IN MCCABE'S OFFICE THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
THIS IS TAKING A BIAS AND SAYING
YOU WILL USE THE MACHINERY OF
GOVERNMENT TO PREVENT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM MAKING A
CHOICE?
THAT'S DISTURBING.
>> JAMES YOU WROTE THIS TODAY IN
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL."
YOU NOTED THAT THE STRZOK EMAIL
WHEN HE RAISED THAT ISSUE OF THE
INSURANCE POLICY, THAT REALLY
JUMPED OUT AT YOU.
HAVING AN OPINION.
IT GOES WAY BEYOND EXTREME BIAS
OR EVEN HATRED OF THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS SUPPORTERS THAT YOU SEE
IN THESE EMAILS.
IT'S SUGGESTING THERE WAS ACTION
TAKEN.
I THINK A REASONABLE READING IS
THESE PEOPLE VIEWED THEIR ROLE
AS PROTECTING AMERICA FROM THE
CONSEQUENCES OF POLITICAL
DECISIONS.
THAT'S NOT THEIR JOB.
THEIR JOB IS TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
IF THERE IS A MORE INNOCENT
EXPLANATION MR. STRZOK WILL WITH
A CHANCE TO TRY TO PROVIDE IT.
I EXPECT A NUMBER OF SUBPOENAS
COMING OUT OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO TALK TO
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WE HAVE SEEN
MENTIONED.
SHOWING THEIR ANTI-TRUMP BIAS
AND THEIR ACTIVISM ON BEHALF OF
THE DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS TOPIC-A FOR FUTURE
HEARINGS.
>> Laura: THESE ARE MOVE ON.ORG
ACTIVISTS.
IT'S ALMOST A CONSPIRACY INSIDE
THE FBI TO DO SOMETHING TO STOP
THIS CANDIDATE FROM GAINING
STEAM.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU WANT SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE TO SUBPOENAED.
THE DOCUMENTS ARE NOT COMING
FAST AS THEY SHOULD BE.
WILL YOU BE ABLE TO GET PETER
STRZOK TO TESTIFY?
>> I THINK WE WILL EVENTUALLY.
REMEMBER, BRUCE OHR, HIGH
RANKING JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL.
FUSION GPS PAID TO DO THE TRUMP
DOSSIER BEFORE THE ELECTION AND
MEETING WITH FUSION GPS AFTER
THE ELECTION AND HIS WIFE WORKS
FOR FUSION GPS.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI KNEE-DEEP
IN THE DOSSIER.
WE NEED TO KNOW:
HOW DID THEY GET THE DOSSIER?
DID THEY PAY FOR IT.
ROSENSTEIN WOULD NOT TELL US IF
YOUR TAX DOLLARS WERE USED FOR
THE DOSSIER.
STRZOK, OHR AND MCCABE NEEDS TO
COME IN.
>> Laura: WHAT KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS ARE THEY HAVING IN
THE OFFICE?
THEY ARE SITTING AROUND
AGONIZING WHETHER DONALD TRUMP
WILL WIN THE PRESIDENCY?
MY GOD, HE IS THE WORST EVER.
WE HAVE TO STOP IT!
THE WHOLE THING IS EMBARRASSING
FOR THE FBI.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE AND JAMES I
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, WHO
TROTTED OUT ROBERT MUELLER AS AN
UNIMPEACH ABLE
INVESTIGATION.
I HAVE TO SAY IN WATCHING THIS
THING PLAY OUT.
I AM NOT IMPRESSED.
WITH HOW HE HANDLED THIS.
>> IT'S HARD TO THINK OF WHAT
TEAM HE COULD HAVE ASSEMBLED
THAT WOULD GIVE HIS
INVESTIGATION LESS CREDIBILITY.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT IN THE OFFICE.
REMEMBER, THESE ARE CAREFUL,
EXPERIENCED LAWYERS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE PUTTING IN
WRITING TO TEXTS.
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT THEY
SAY WHEN THEY ABOUT THEIR PLANS
FOR TRUMP WHEN THEY ARE NOT
RECORDING IT.
THAT DISCUSSION TALKING ABOUT
THE INSURANCE POLICY SEEMS TO BE
STRZOK AND PAGE.
THE WHOLE THING.